foreign
s us up next in Cleveland Renee welcome
to the Ramsay show
thank you so much for taking my call
um recently got married and we got
ourselves into a hundred and twelve
thousand dollars of debt yes just from
the wedding just from the wedding oh my
God
holy cow and I wasn't even invited
the party of this the party of the
century does that ring look like a disco
ball yeah exactly it's pretty much that
yes oh my goodness okay yes well we're
here so so I want to
um we you know other than a old
um
College you know loan debt of about 40
Grand we don't have any other Consumer
Debt we own free properties together one
fully paid off probably worth about 600
to 700 okay the other two have mortgages
on it
and he my husband has about
395 in stocks and bonds oh okay so
there's there's good news here which is
you guys have a pile of money to clean
this up the question is is he willing to
cash out those stocks and bonds to put
you guys in a place financially that
will cause you to succeed in this
marriage
foreign
question I'm sorry that's all right okay
hey we're here with you you know we've
all done stupid stuff with many many
zeros attached so we were poking fun at
you earlier but we definitely know the
weight of what you're facing right now
and we're definitely here to walk with
you are those are those tears because of
the arguments you guys have had around
this yes what it what is the latest
conversations been like when you bring
this up and say hey we're in a big pile
of debt I want to get out of this
foreign well the the other thing is is
that the day after we returned from our
uh wedding weekend he lost his job
[Music]
and he was making over 200k a year okay
okay Renee and how long ago was this
are you working at all Renee
what is your name
that's a great income
okay what's he doing right now is he
currently looking for work yeah okay
what was he doing
yes
in the automobile industry okay
I have a question uh I have a question
about these properties so you mentioned
three properties one paid off two with
mortgages the one that's paid off is
that your primary residence or is that
it is not it is not it's just a vacation
home okay so that's the vacation home so
that that means the other two with
mortgages one of those is your primary
residence correct okay can you tell me
the numbers on that like what the
mortgage is worth and what you owe
sure so
um let me actually pull that out because
I I I've since had you know we've had
some serious conversations yeah what I'm
getting at is is getting rid of at least
one of these mortgages uh not the
primary residence one and clearing up
some money there and George mentioned
the stocks and bonds if they're not if
they're non-retirement related
definitely wanting to liquidate those
okay so that's what we're that's what
we're getting at so yeah so the one uh
that we currently live in
um probably has about
235k on it worth about maybe 350.
um the other one with a mortgage is
actually in another state and it has a
much higher
um you know it probably has about 200
inequity 200k in equity
um but the mortgage is about 550. yeah I
if I and this is what I would do if I
were in your shoes if I woke up in your
shoes today I would get rid of that
third property that's got the 200k and
equity
and I would take that money and I would
use it to start paying off this wet I'd
for sure knock out the student loan
because that's it's just the student
loan and the wedding debt correct that's
your only debt correct I would knock out
that student loan I'd keep a thousand
aside for any savings in case you don't
have baby step one and then whatever's
left I throw it towards the wedding and
then if there's any debt left I'd start
liquidating some of those stocks
okay now
um okay thank you for that I I guess
prior because of the location of the um
the third property we've been probably
bringing in about 200k at 200k my
apologies 2K in rental income
um that's per month the one that's out
of state
correct yeah just because it's in a yeah
it's it's in a good location uh the one
that's got the 200k
um
200k is that your net profit
uh or is that maybe because you still
got to pay the mortgage on that
correct that's my net profit yeah okay I
mean that's not that's good it's good
that you're making a profit on it my
concern is that it's out of state and
then my bigger concern is that you've
got I mean you called us in tears but
because of this debt so at that point
you know you're really weighing the
opportunity cost between the two do you
want to get out of debt how quickly can
we get out of debt uh the other thing
that I'm hearing in this call is and
George correct me if I'm wrong but it
kind of feels like we can give you
um our take on this and we can say hey
this is what we think you need to do but
your husband being on on page with this
is is the other part do you think that
if if he comes home tonight or if you
guys have this conversation and say Hey
I was talking with some experts here is
the plan that they have advised us to
follow what do you think his response is
going to be
well he'll be happy because it's my
property
[Music]
so he's like well that's your business
don't try to sell one of mine but that
worries me because you're married now
it's we it's our properties and so I
want him thinking that way and if he's
not we have a deeper issue here but as
far as liquidating the stocks and bonds
there is going to be tax implications on
the gain so you want to work with the
tax Pro on that to make sure that you're
going to be able to cover this and
understand what's going on there but as
far as this property goes it I don't
want to be a long distance landlord I
mean this is a lot of work for 20K I
agree and so this this cleans up all of
your Consumer Debt and gives you a pile
of money at the end of that and which is
your fully funded emergency fund so this
one property puts you in a completely
different place financially if you sell
it absolutely and I'm I wanted to ask
just because you know I'm always
thinking about the baby steps do you
have any other money saved like just
laying around saved up for a rainy day
three to six months anything like that
yes okay I do I've got about 45k so here
think about it like this Renee if you've
if you follow the advice that we've
given you you're still going to be
millionaires you've got this vacation
home that's worth 700 you've got your
primary real estate that's worth 350
just right there alone your net worth
millionaires all right and then you know
I don't think that I don't know how much
is in the stocks and bonds that you have
you may not have to liquidate all of
that but do you see what I'm saying
about
390. oh come on now so this is great if
I'm in your shoes I am selling that
third property and cashing out the
stocks and bonds making sure I can pay
the taxes on that and that's going to
put you guys in a completely different
place because you can pay off the other
mortgage now you have zero payments in
the world and everything is Cash flowing
with a hundred percent profit going to
you yeah with very little stress in your
life as newlyweds I know that's right
suddenly you're you're wiping those
tears and you're rejoicing because
you're suddenly ahead of 90 of the
people out here do you see that yes yes
now we need him to see it yeah
hey
hopefully he did but I do like the
solution I'll be honest I I've been
afraid to let go of that because because
it is mine it's the only property that I
actually own and it's been a cash cow
for me for a long time but you're right
when you put it in perspective and say
only 20 grand a year like forget it you
make over triple that and you can always
get another property that's the thing
the way we're setting you up you'll be
able to if you want to purchase more
real estate you'll be able to do it
you'll be able to cash flow it and it's
going to be a blessing not a burden and
he's going to be back to work in no time
making great money but right now this is
a great moment for you guys to reset
Clean Slate this is we now how are we
going to set ourselves up financially
for a successful marriage for successful
wealth building for the future and this
is a way to do it and it's a good
problem to have when you have all this
money sitting around in different
Pockets put it to good use and make
yourself free